but as you wish mr. Tito you were an
entrepreneur then he became the Russian
presidents Commissioner for
entrepreneurs rights now you want to be
President yourself why this a chance
President Putin has the best chances of
winning I'm running to show that there
are other groups out there who have a
different point of view to those who
support Putin's politics I'm clearly a
human rights advocate who's been in the
president's camp but I've also taken on
the task of creating a more liberal
society let's talk more concretely about
your goal of making society more liberal
what exactly do you not like about
Vladimir Putin spoke Outen and his team
of experts have done a lot to stabilize
Russia and after the chaos of the 90s
it's been good for the country but
prices were higher eyes dropped and we
had no alternatives to make money those
who chose Pearson and I would say by
contrast our model is competitive and
market oriented promote small and
mid-sized businesses come Korean English
so you are using this election campaign
to promote your ideas but you yourself
don't want to be the president am i
right my candidacy is a chance to prove
that our economic strategy is the right
one you sure that we can influence the
political power brokers in this country
seem strong chast and I'll think they'll
see it they won't make a radical swing
to the left back towards Soviet
economics because if oil doesn't go up
again but we only have two choices a
planned economy like in Soviet times or
we can move the country forward
Curtin's biggest critic Alexei Navalny
has been barked you say you don't want
to be president at all
what kind of election is this if
candidates who want to be President are
bird and those who are loud don't want
to be president at all is that Dimmick
yes I didn't do that Kotori there's only
one candidate who's been able to
convince the people that he's the one
who can maintain order and be a strong
leader at home and on the world stage
and the people will vote for him
Ludacris who's in your dream in bloody
me Putin newtonia of course no one will
dispute it so I and all the other
candidates have to be realistic at the
same time we have to do all we can to
get our points over because that those
that are bleep rough that should never
only take part in the election anything
only when you're watching Alexei Navalny
has a strange understanding of the law
he says the Constitution is on his side
but the issue here is purely a political
one
the fact he's missing makes these
elections incomplete think he would have
got many votes his target demographic is
too small and estudia correctly you are
against him not being able to take part
from a political standpoint
anyone who represents a group in society
should have the right to be a candidate
and run against everyone else come query
and since I've seen a little game do you
feel sorry for him yes - don't you like
which in Ceylonese me I think he's a
strong and courageous man but I have
absolutely no sympathy for him he's
strong but I don't think he has any fear
like a pro any opposed
is he a good politician what he doesn't
have any good ideas he has a list of
popular slogans and nothing else what
he's done very well is to communicate
his ideas to the people he's very modern
a politician who understands technology
all of the process you organize across
the country a proof of that but never
only is a complete politician I have my
doubts you say you are no politician but
even so you're a presidential candidate
so you must have an opinion on key
issues in Russian politics for example
the Crimea question which of course also
affects its economy
so the sanctions were applied after the
Crimean unification as it's known here
in Russia or the illegal annexation as
it's called in the West should the
status of Crimea remain as is my opinion
is the same as it's always been from day
one when Crimea returned to Russia and
I'll stick by it
Crimea belongs to us for now the
situation there is frozen we can talk
about creating a special economic zone
to each tensions but Crimea has no place
in international politics like the
former Baltic States yes but one day if
the Baltic countries became independent
again will Crimea also become Ukrainian
again Crimea will never belong to
Ukraine there might be other solutions
to the conflict but not that one mr. T
Tov on March 18th at 8 p.m. most of the
polling stations might be closed but the
situation is pretty clear what's your
prognosis we did win I don't know what
the result will be our target is to get
more than 5% if we clear that hurdle
will be very satisfied nature to
encourage tourism Tatiana's but it's
touristy top Russian presidential
candidate thank you for the interview